all he says we have somebody else who
would like to say congratulations our
buddy who recently visited us the great
actor Bryan Cranston London Wow Wow
Bryan
wow that sounds so natural how are you
congratulations
ten years man yeah thank you thank you I
and I know that you said that you would
have joined us in studio but you're
you're working in London so what tell us
are you on a movie set there no I'm
rehearsing for a play that begins in
November all the way through the end of
March called Network remember the movies
in the seventies yeah yeah they're
making into a play and I get to be
Howard Beale I'm mad as hell and I'm not
well he was very appropriate these days
yeah but I'm glad you called in and we
had such a great time you know when you
you gave us a gift off of a recent movie
and we have that proudly displayed in
the in the home mancave so once again
that's a gift that keeps on giving and
we really appreciate that what is a
palace between two straight I told my
wife the gift that you gave me was
something to do with a well penal prop
is that what we can kind of say it would
in a movie so she said wait Bryan
Cranston got you what and I go um here
I'll show you hon and she was very
impressed that you would that that's
what you thought of me you know when you
saw that you thought of me that's
entirely correct I just I'll make this
quick
you and the damnit I think you guys are
great loved listening to you it's a
little difficult here in London but we
managed and
what a great 10 years breaking off from
the mothership you're doing your own
thing and it's fun listening to you
bring a lot of joy and entertainment to
my life
thank you Brian and I didn't know this
but Paulie said I was the inspiration
for Breaking Bad that I was breaking
away from the mothership and then that
that I was breaking really bad and then
you decided to do Breaking Bad and you
just added meth to it I added the Dan
ants you added meth and that's the
difference there so thank you thank you
for that tribute boy boy that's it
that's a huge stretch think we're losing
contact with Brian Brian thank you and
good luck with the play all right thank
all right no there you go Bryan Cranston
that's that's good stuff the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience